You're trying to match matches your
weaknesses.
The Parker,
pretty much everybody knows what those
weaknesses are.
You know,
some people would smoke too much,
too much,
and some people would be unfaithful and
have a comfort productive areas.
Some people would end up on the street
because they would generate.
Everybody kind of knows how they fall
apart if they fell apart in their own
idiosyncratic and spectacular manner.
Those sorts of things that keep you
awake at night.
If you.
If you contemplate them deeply,
where would you be interested?
Five years.
If you let her go directly to hell,
that's useful.
That's useful because then see it's one
thing that want to make yourself because
you see them.
What you're doing is moving.
You have something that you want,
but that's whole hope is a powerful
emotion,
but terror acts and so one of the things
out with my clinical clients,
it's their baby.
They don't have a job.
They really like,
you know,
and it's grinding away at your soul and
just leave your job into another job.
That's actually a really complicated
problem,
right?
If you don't like your job,
it's not just a psychological problem,
have to have a job,
otherwise you die.
So it's a cycle.
And so just changing the battery,
just adjusting yourself psychologically.
You might be planning to change your
job,
you have to update your CV and maybe you
have to make your skills and we've gotta
figure out how to be a little more
credit,
Melinda,
an interview and you have to overcome
your fear of rejection.
Like there may be all sorts of things
that African set yourself up to move
laterally or let's say to a different
position when it's more engaging and uh,
you know,
you might be,
you might be willing to do that.
Um,
and so you were afraid of doing now
and you think,
well,
if I'm afraid of it,
why should I do it?
People ask themselves the same question
like I have a difficult conversation to
have with their wives or their children
or their parents,
you know,
because a lot of us are very conflict
diverse and there are difficult
conversations to have.
And the reason is is because they're
awkward and make us afraid.
So you might think,
well,
why the hell is it makes you afraid?
Why not just not,
which is one of the ideas that keeps
people in jobs they hate and in
relationships with and,
and it stops them from repairing or
relationships with some very difficult
thing to do.
And the answer is,
well,
let's imagine that you just keep doing
the thing that you don't like,
that you don't change it because you're
afraid to,
well,
are you afraid of what happens if you
don't change it?
And if you lay out this little hail,
but I described it really in a one way
so you know where you would degenerate
if you were going to degenerate.
And then you look at life and say,
well here's a bunch of things that are
not doing because I'm afraid that's,
you know,
keeping me secure.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
It's just taking you to that place that
you lay down.
It's an absolute catastrophe.
And so sometimes the answer to why
should I do this thing that I've been
putting off is well,
otherwise they end up in this particular
hell.
I already know.
I already know the parameters of and so
hope can help you move out of that.
It would be better if I did this,
but fear of not doing it and the
consequences.
That's where you've been and what's
better yet is to have both of them
working in tandem,
so psychologists figured this out when
they were looking at sphere years ago
because I'm trying to figure out how to
motivate them to do things like run down
a major update and reward.
Turns out that a hungry,
hungry,
rapid run down.
A little bays quite rapidly get a
cheesy,
but if that brand is,
if you.
If you have the hungry wrap and you walk
in some capital,
expats are terrified of cats and even if
they've never met a capital,
just a different smell.
The cash,
they know what cat smell like and like.
And so if you take your hungry,
grab and throw in a little caterpillar,
he'll sit down that runway like nap much
faster than one that's just hungry.
So running away from something that
you're terrified out.
We're avoiding something that your
property terrified though and running
towards something you want is a good way
of being maximally motivate people and
so with the second part of that program
we have people,
they don't have very detailed plan about
their position in the briefing.
If April's prior quiz tools and figure
why would you be better if he would take
the first goal was how would your
families be better?
Also with maybe how it would be a
benefit to the community if you would
take that book because it'd be nice if
you could sort yourself out in ways that
also sorted out your family and then
also sort of your community and since
you're making a plan,
but where the hell no name for all
three.
It's more sustainable anyways.
Right.
So this broke the famous psychologist
show,
Piaget hold,
that included a braided state.
He said that it's like a game that
everyone wants to play with.
It's better if you're going to play a
game to play a game that everyone wants
to play and that's a good.
That's a good indication that it's a
good game.
And so if you could figure out how to
fix yourself off in a way that would
simple phineas,
they fix up your family and your
community.
It's like,
hey,
everybody wins and maybe it would be
good to play a game that everybody wins.
So we don't think of games that often,
but it's certainly possible in 25 exists
and so well back to courage and that
free speech.
One of the things that I do recommend
that people who try these programs is
that they do the map because if that
plan has been that the no plan at all
and you're going to come up with a
better plan because what they have and
you know,
and so it's either a bad plan or no plan
and no Glenn is way worse than a bad.
At least when you implemented that plan
and you start walking towards what the
plan lays out,
you'll see specifically where it is that
you're an error like specifically.
And you'll learn from that.
And then you can use what you learn
while you're making the mistakes.
Implementing your plan to make a better
plan.
And if you keep doing that eventually,
like there'll be a lot of failure along
the way.
That's the adventure of your life,
by the way.
If you do that and you keep laying on
plant and learning painfully from your
failures and then correcting the planet,
what'll happen is that you get on target
as you move through life,
and even though you're hitting a moving
target,
because life is complicated.